okay so previously on heavy spoilers who
were covering Rick and Morty season 6
every single week however there was a
bit of a break but we're back with
episode 7 packed with Easter eggs
callbacks and little details this
breakdown is going to be going through
it all to bring you a big review of the
latest entry titled full meta jackrick
this title is of course a not just
Stanley Kubrick's Full Metal Jacket the
episode starts off in the style of a
previously on recap which is used to
great effect and it only fill in the Gap
but also set up the premise of the
episode early on Rick and Morty find
themselves trapped in a previously on
segment and the intro follows them as
they break on through it to me it's the
most creative opening I've seen for a
Rick and Morty episode and it's so well
put together chronicling the events of
this season whilst adding some new stuff
we start off with a clip from bethic
Twin stinked with space Beth admitting
that she had sex with Beth next we cut
episode 6 after Rick fixed the portal
gun now from this point we get a new
sequence which was added to the titles
and it shows Rick and Morty meeting Jack
the Ripper you can see that he's just
carried out one of his killings because
of the feat that are popping up in the
bottom corner this is something that's
only been used in the title sequence and
at first I genuinely questioned whether
I'd missed an episode hashtag heavy
spoilers falling off as always and they
end up passing through this scene later
on when they invade the titles we then
get Summer announcing I'm pregnant and
this happens at her 18th birthday we
learned the same thing happened with
Beth as well and then cut to it raining
meatballs clear reference to the movie
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs and
before Rick can fully work out what's
happening we're transported Jerry's
funeral we learned that he died whilst
getting stung by bees
Oh wrong Channel and this is a reference
to my girl namely how Macaulay Culkin's
character Thomas died spoiler alert
later on in the green mile-esque public
execution scene we see Beth is the one
who's been sentenced to death but being
the suspect that killed Jerry think
Jerry's funeral was swapped in to try
and throw Rick off but he's still very
suspicious also summer is heavily
pregnant at this point and she vows to
call her baby Jerry Jr Tony Hawk then
makes a cameo to thank them for solving
a murder and shows of course throw in
random celebrity ones that they keep
constantly going on about now Rick
manages to predict how the algorithm of
the previously unconstruct is working
and after he gets Modi to propose this
sends them to a Cliffside wedding Rick
brings up that for their honeymoon they
should let's go to a steel chamber line
with ionized deuterium why because the
charge acts as a narrative to celerate
by using the phrase next time on the
able to draw previously on how to has
the typical previously on voice guy
shows up wearing a letterman jacket with
p l written on it and they jump onto him
which pulls them into the intro sequence
I rarely laugh out loud but this had me
absolutely dying as they went through
the famous sequences that we've seen
over and over this includes the scene in
which Rick leaves Modi behind to die
which Rick tells Morty that he shouldn't
look at but because of this scene
there's been so many different theories
on what's going on with this opening and
there are some Clues throughout the
season that have hinted towards what's
happened here I had to dig into the
archives of Reddit to see what the
theories were and someday back as long
as seven years ago found one from four
and one punt talking about how the pilot
has a rick explaining things to a Morty
even though it's sad that he always has
a Morty this made people think that he
was actually with a replacement Morty
and the original one was the one that we
see die here then theories started
popping up that this is actually evil
Morty his origin story is unknown and
many people have speculated that he
managed to escape this and this is the
event that set him up on his path I
think it's more likely the former
because there's no way Morty is getting
out of that now they go through the
glimpses at the new clips including the
butter one with Rick calling it the best
episode from here they're finally
electrocuted by the title sequence which
takes us into the rest of the episode
now this video is sponsored by kamiko or
knives they're running a massive Black
Friday day sale right now and giving up
to 85 off along with free shipping
however [ __ ] shut that front door shut
the box lid followers of this channel in
the air they're cutting prices even
further and giving an extra 50 off
they're a great gift for a loved one and
they come in this amazing heavy duty Ash
box which also has a certificate of
authenticity in it I can't even lift it
it's utterly heavy duty there you go
it's an amazing gift and you can treat
either yourself or a loved one this
Christmas each knife is also
individually inspected and it comes with
a lifetime guarantee made with high
quality Japanese steel these have also
been a complete life changer in the
kitchen used by Michelin chefs all over
the world and I can definitely see why
they've really helped out in the kitchen
when it comes to cooking meals and also
cutting up ingredients because of their
single bevel Edge kamikoto knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge that
you just can't get with other knives
they can cut through your rib eye like
butter and will save you so much time
when you're prepping food I absolutely
love them and I'm definitely going to be
picking up more to give my family this
great gift over Christmas like I said
along with the Black Friday sale
kamikodo are also giving 50 off every
single purchase to followers of this
channel so that's up to 85 off in the
Black Friday sale along with free
shipping and you also get 50 off if
you're a follower of this Channel all
you have to do is go to kamikodo.com
heavy spoilers and you get that extra
fifty dollars off that's kamikodo.com
heavy spoilers for the extra fifty
dollars off get a set for yourself or
for a loved one at kamikoto.com heavy
spoilers now this entry has heavy
references to storytrain from the
episode never Rick and Morty from
beginning to end there's several
different methods of Storytelling and
huge shout outs to tvtropes.org for
specifying that the entire episode has
conventional troping meta storytelling
callbacks fourth wall breaking elements
and lamp shading of the fact that it's a
meta episode along with previously on we
get other characters that fit this kind
of wordplay like mislead flashback
Connie to new error protagonic Mr twist
bretcon tagaman and Joseph Campbell now
the latter is the famous writer who
basically outlined the hero's journey
this storytelling device showed the
stages that a hero must go through and
it's been adapted into several movies
games and books basically tells the
origin story of a protagonist and has
them go through a call to Adventure
Supernatural Aid meeting a guardian who
ends up dying Abyss which is basically
when they're at the lowest point a
transformation atonement and basically
then they come out on top he wants them
to have more season one adventures and
it makes sense that Camel would say this
as he basically outlined the origin
story Model Mori becomes self-aware and
previously on talks about how cool this
is so basically it sort of reminded me
of the She-Hulk finale in Rick hilarious
it calls it bullsh in order to escape
previously on breaks through the fourth
wall and Rick gets MBR glasses that help
show the inner workings of the show now
firstly we see a Deus Ex machinae if you
didn't pronounce this deus ex machina
some point in your life then me and you
we're not built the same this translates
from Latin to mean Guard from the
machine in storytelling terms it's used
when a character is in a seemingly
helpless situation and someone or
something pops up out of nowhere to save
them at the last second this basically
happens when Jesus drops down to save
previously on and then later on when
previously on takes out Jesus we also
see chekhov's gun and this thing
originates from the idea that if there's
a gun on the wall in act 1 then it has
to be used in act three more literally
it was used in Sean of the dead but it
basically means that if you set
something up early on that you should
pay it off later in the story we also
see gratuitous violence foreshadowing of
the telescope an action enhancer
motorbike along with a ticking clock
along the top Rick says it's bad when
they constantly do this kind of stuff
and that the fourth wall breaking lines
should just be left to him Rick also
mentions Moonlighting season 3 which is
where Bruce Willis got his big break and
a journey after previously on here we
see one of Joseph Campbell's initial
tropes which is is the trial mountain
now typically a hero would have to
overcome someone like this early on to
build themselves up Rick feels like the
longer they stay there the more their
credibility will fade away and he
mentions it being like 10 Space Jam
cameos sort of roasting themselves here
as the pair of course did Cameo in the
latest Space Jam and previously on
starts to pray and after the arrival of
Jesus we meet story Lord now he planned
to trap them here after they trapped him
in a Bible episode and the entire energy
he's just seeking out motivation Jesus
goes on the attack and Mori calls us out
as being similar to South Park which
saved me from doing it Jesus also breaks
Rick's back and it plays out much like
how Bane did it Batman in The Dark
Knight Rises Bruce having to escape the
prison was also a silicon seat to the
hero's journey with him having to
overcome adversity story Lord leaves
much to the surprise of Jesus they bring
up how he has the potential to become an
unlikely Ally looking at you entire Fast
and the Furious franchise however this
day is sex Machina is taken out by its
own deus ex machina and previously on he
sucks on his Achilles heel and sends him
into his own previously on now stabbing
some on the Achilles heels has been used
a lot to take people out it's popped up
in things like Pet Cemetery Troy
obviously and a lot of TV shows and
movies it is previously on segment we
see that he's joined by a woman who's
similar magara from the film Hercules
now this is actually Mary Magdalene and
if you're familiar with the Bible you'll
know that you travel with Jesus and all
of his disciples she was present at his
crucifixion which we see along with him
being resurrected now in this previously
on Section he basically traveled through
history and met Napoleon fought the Loch
Ness monster Dracula and lastly he
became a billionaire that tried to
resurrect Mary previously on fed on his
potential are we watching his
quote-unquote story oh he gave up his
immortality after being struck by
lightning very similar to storms in
Highlander and finally he died in a
hospital bed after being seen by a nurse
called Mary
oh
I'm not crying you're crying
now Rick Knox previously on out and we
got a story Lord to see him going to the
address on the back of the story train
box which is listed as gleap Globe
Boulevard there's also the word ASAT and
this means an inferior substitute it
says it's a citadel and now the writer
was seen as a god he's really just a bum
who's cooking a hot dog over a lighter
this is the story Train Rider and we
discover who was cast out after the
episode was poorly received but but I I
quite like it now in the background on a
whiteboard we can see a drawing of the
story train as well as rickleberry Tales
which to the best of my knowledge is in
an episode title that we've had yet and
the writer says he came up with his
title because he was asked to do a story
based on the Canterbury Tales however in
the end they switch gears and told them
to do one based on the Batman episode
titled almost got him this is why we see
Batman poker and in case you haven't
seen that episode go check it out
because it's one of the best ones in the
Animated Series here he talks about how
he was given a show to work with and
made the episode as best occurred but
that it would never have worked he also
brings up other website story slash
train.com never worked and it showed how
the creative team had no faith in this
actual episode now I did Google this to
make sure it definitely wasn't live and
it wasn't however the website mentioned
at the end with a plushie does in fact
pop up this takes you to a site that you
can get a rick plush from but
unfortunately it's not available in this
universe story Lord kidnaps him and
elsewhere Rick drags previously onto a
forest this is the home of the
self-referential 6 which only has five
members because Mr twist constantly
makes whoever enters the sixth as part
of the twist they journey in through the
front door which is also a Trope and we
meet mislead she basically damn me I'm
saying basically a lot in this video
anyway she rep that's becoming its own
Trope and she represents the character
who has an uneasy pass with a
protagonist and dramatically hits them
before forming an ally ship though Lando
never smacked tan he did approach him
saying that he had a lot of nerve and
this happens a lot when introducing new
characters out they want to tie into an
unexplored backstory we also meet
flashback who is based on the flash and
he has the ability to jump into people's
past to discover new information there's
also Connie to nuity error and
protagonic who can make any character
the lead he actually hits A God Called
Marvin and we follow him home as he
returns back to his wife we see a 70s
style sitcom for him where we see his
life as a security guard Loch Ness pops
up again and we see spend his entire
life running away from danger Rick
smashes protagonist's device and we see
a grenade roll in with smash cut written
on it a smash cut is when we jump from
one location to the next without a
moment's notice so that the viewer
doesn't really have time to question
what's really going on we see on Mr
twist spell that he was the one who
threw it and Mori has a twist for him he
does something pathetic and seems to
have done no damage but in reality he
bit the key off one of his smash cut
grenades the old pin out the grenade is
its own Trope and the first one that
spring things to mind for this is the
ending of Live Die Repeat because I
watched it last week also sometimes
called Edge of Tomorrow and in some
countries it's even called All You Need
Is kill not joking the movie has three
names anyway this takes them to the
center of the prison to free Brett Khan
his cell is surrounded by Sports because
as Rick says it's the opposite of a
story Mori brings up how stupid it is
he's called bretcon and how easily that
it could be the original word retcon
retcon then retcons this to have the
name record
sorry like
Brett Khan then retcons it to have the
name retcon who got through it now at
this point we also get a return of the
butter robot
what is my purpose pass the butter
thank you
guy first showed up all the way back in
2014 and I loved seeing him back now
they want to use retcon to make it so
that they never went there and they end
up bringing him retcon is your god-like
character and you can completely see why
he was locked up in the first place guy
can alter reality at a whim and
following another or Campbell's story
tropes we see as they head into a low
point before being saved by someone who
becomes a mental figure looking at you
Obi-Wan and he serves them up some
Campbell's Soup which he admitters on
the nose and we see that he also saved
previously on previously on becomes the
unlikely Ally and in his room we can see
there's a burning book an eye in a
triangle as well as a photo of the
Invisible Man Campbell is known for the
book The Hero with a thousand faces and
the room itself is surround with lots of
heads the zorso and araboros which is a
snake eating its own tail this is used
in storytelling to represent a
self-destructive nature and we could
also see a bottle of alcohol standing on
the table this is called writer's
courage which no oil prices for guessing
what that's about years play out
apparently with them living through
trials and character rocks they get
called back their future rip-offs and
the pair of course started off as
parodies of Doc and Marty other tropes
to show that a lot of time has passed
are included such as Morty growing a
beard which is typically something that
male characters do women are usually
made to be pregnant as well but since
essenone here he has to do that too the
event she returned back through the
title sequence and we see that story
Lord has built a massive machine that
sucks in motivation giant machines are
normally a third act Trope and we get a
beam even shooting into the sky for it
superhero movies are loaded with this
and the third act normally comes with
the characters getting a new suit too
this is also the case here with Rick and
Morty showing up wearing two new ones
leads to a big battle with Rick's ABS
being referred to as come gutters a big
fight ensues with it leading to conveyor
belting through a factory which is also
sometimes used as a place for an epic
conclusion a third ax normally pair
characters off with that equals and we
see that Mori is matched with the writer
he tries to talk him down and Campbell
appears as a force ghost in order to
advise him he also mentions his green
arrow script and we get the idea from
what he says that it was terrible he
stops the machine and we see that
everyone gets their motivation back
story Lord says that he wants to become
the new Mr Nimbus and he himself was a
character who was brought into the story
apparently sharing a pass with Rick that
we never saw story Lord gets two trops
on the way out and he dangles over the
edge before falling to his death this is
Then followed with him giving his final
words whilst the writer cradles him in
his arms he suffocates him using the
plushie which we know from the website
is now 50 heavier the writer returns
home and starts scrambling ideas about a
Magic Pencil and the story of a writer
that he gets very excited about as we
learned earlier Joseph Campbell sees
everything and he desperately tries to
tell him it's a bad idea but
unfortunately he can't see him and the
entire episode itself has been about all
the conventions of writing so I'll write
a writing a thing about themselves is
sort of lampshading that joke and
basically come back that word basically
something up the entire episode could of
the post create scene tag to see tag man
who's basically the Hulk in Thor
Ragnarok battling in a gladiatorial
Arena he destroys his foes with ease and
that ends the episode and what a bloody
episode it was such a good return
especially after the break and this had
so much going on with it that it was
difficult to not Marvel at how crazy it
went this is one of the most meta
entries in a show that already breaks
the fourth wall consistently and had a
blast watching it even if the breakdown
was a nightmare to put together but I
hope you enjoyed it and obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it in the
comments section below if you are a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of House of the Dragon
season one on the 15th of December and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and and
the winners of the last one are on the
screen right now save that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
anyone smells to watch then we've got a
video linked on screen right now that
the algorithm has told me is the best
for you a click best for the viewer and
it's picked that out so it's definitely
going to be the best video that you
could watch right now if it's not me I
don't know what the hell's going on but
yeah hopefully I see you over there
right after this by the way thank you
for clicking this take care peace